cada vez que una filtración política ve
la luz en perú la cúpula del ejecutivo
tiembla y la historia ha demostrado que
incluso cae en mayo el diario peruano
gestión publicó una explosiva
investigación en la que el hasta
entonces desconocido cantante de ricardo
cisneros que presumía de su cercanía con
el mandatario suscribió nueve contratos
con el ministerio de cultura- entre 2018
año en que vizcarra ha asumido la
presidencia y 2020 por uno de ellos le
pagaron hasta ocho mil quinientos
dólares se trató de una conferencia
virtual que ofreció en plena pandemia
sin mostrar experiencia en el tema
recientemente se publicaron tres audios
en los que vizcarra estaría ajustando su
versión sobre los vínculos con el
artista el congreso controlado por
opositores fujimoristas vio una
oportunidad como todo favor 205
congresistas
en contra 36 abstención del 24
en consecuencia ha sido emitida la
moción de orden del día del pedido de
vacancia de presidente de república
esto abre las puertas para someter a
vizcarra a un juicio de destitución y el
gobierno reaccionó la actitud del
presidente el congreso han sido
temeraria
al pretender involucrar a las fuerzas
armadas en un proceso político los
antecesores de vizcarra que estuvieron
en el centro de filtraciones no salieron
me librados los vladivideos una
filtración que reveló los sobornos que
recibían políticos en el gobierno de
fujimori en el 2000 terminaron con su
renuncia
en 2018 una grabación en la que el
congresista kenji fujimori negociaba con
sus padres para evitar un proceso de
vacancia sobre kuczynski a cambio de
indultar a su padre terminó en la salida
del presidente es que yo renuncie tendrá
vizcarra mejor suerte